Your system. You need to install something or figure out
what's using all the disk space or something else that
you might normally go to the command line for. However
with AI and cognotic, you can have an LLM write
the shell script for you. You start with the, you
start at the goal tab of the system wizard and
type in what you want to do. Let's, for this
demonstration, do, Listen. What's
the running processes. We saved the goal. We are using
Windows here. This also supports Shell, which is Linux
or Mac OS. It specifically uses Bash, but we are
going to be using Windows and PowerShell. We list running
processes. In settings, we make sure that we have a
model selected. We have Gemini 3 Flash Preview we're going
to use in this demo, and then we go to
the pipeline and generate a shell script. Yeah
And here we go. We can either use this directly
in our own show or we can click run and
fix to test the script. Now, in this run and
auto-fix session that appears, If an error occurs
it will look into the error and then Try
to code up a fix. If an error were to
happen, you would be able to run again. Well, you
would be able to. Fixed it. You would be able
to retry the execution in this interface. However, the
first execution was successful, and it is listing all the
processes that we can view here. The UI shows that
the command succeeded. Note that the UI does not show
the output of the command. You have to go into
the session rank to view that detail. And there you
go. That is the system wizard. That is the System
Wizard application. I hope you find it useful.